if you're building a cross-platform
mobile app today there are two
heavyweights competing for your
mindshare in the red corner we have
flutter from google and in the blue
corner we have react native from
facebook these tools can achieve the
same fundamental goal build apps for
multiple platforms like ios android and
the web from a single code base but
there's a world of difference in both
how they work and the developer
experience no matter which one you
choose the other one automatically
becomes your arch nemesis because you
don't choose anything but the absolute
best technology out there to figure out
which one is best i built the exact same
chat app with both react native and
flutter using firebase as the back end
in today's video we'll dive into a
detailed side-by-side comparison of
features tooling developer experience
performance and of course the code by
the end of the video you'll know exactly
which one fits best into your ideology
but this isn't a line by line coding
tutorial if you want to learn how to
build these apps from scratch i created
two separate pro lessons on fireship
that will teach you how to build them
step by step let's start by comparing
the programming languages between these
two frameworks in react native we code
apps in javascript with react being a
required ui library so it's almost like
an extension of the javascript language
and it also supports typescript if you
want to add a type system on top of
javascript javascript was never really
designed to build mobile apps so flutter
was implemented with a different
language called dart which is a language
optimized for compiling to multiple
platforms with ahead of time and just in
time compilation that results in various
performance advantages but it's a
language that not many people know
outside of flutter it has a syntax that
somewhat resembles typescript so curly
brace developers generally have an easy
time getting started with it but that's
a major question to ask yourself do i
want to learn a whole new language or do
i want to stick with what i already know
now let's look at the ecosystem behind
these frameworks they're both two of the
most actively worked on github repos in
the world react native comes from
facebook which has been criticized as
being an evil tech corporation while
flutter comes from google which has been
criticized for being an evil tech
corporation building high quality
cross-platform mobile apps is an
extremely difficult technical challenge
and that's why you need to bring in an
evil tech corporation to get the job
done right but you'll notice a huge
difference in development philosophy
react native just like react for the web
is designed to be minimal it provides
some base components but leaves
everything else to the open source
community and that means a complete
react native project generally requires
a lot of third-party dependencies
depending on the features that you need
flutter on the other hand comes with a
huge widget library out of the box and
the flutter team maintains many plugins
that you'll commonly need like ones to
access the native camera on a device
dart also has a package manager called
pub and there's a huge ecosystem of open
source packages for flutter as well the
bottom line is they both have huge
communities to get pretty much anything
you can imagine done now let's look at
their underlying architectures first off
how does react native work under the
hood it runs two separate javascript
threads one is the main thread to run
your app on whatever native platform and
the other is a thread to run the
business logic of your application these
threads are isolated from each other but
sometimes they need to interact so
there's a bridge in the middle where
they can pass serialized messages back
and forth the cool thing about this
system is that it allows a javascript
app to communicate with the native
platform so when react native renders a
component it's a truly native component
on the corresponding platform it's not
just like a react website bundled as a
mobile app it's truly rendering native
components and that means your ui will
look exactly like those native
components are intended even when things
change in the future now how does
flutter work instead of using native ui
components flutter has its own high
performance rendering engine built with
c plus and skia that renders its own
custom pixels to the screen with
compiled native code that allows it to
render pixel perfect versions of ios and
android widgets while also making it
possible to paint your own custom pixels
to the screen kind of like a gaming
engine like unity this allows it to
paint smooth graphics without the need
for a bridge although it does have a
system called platform channels that
allows you to communicate with the
native system when you need native
features or if you want to integrate
native code at the end of the day though
architecture doesn't matter a whole lot
what matters is that you create a good
user experience and have fun doing it so
now let's compare the developer
experience starting with the initial
setup to get started with react native
you can generate a new app by running
npx react native init from the command
line and you can optionally pass in a
template here with something like native
base to give you a nice looking ui out
of the gate and you might also use expo
here instead of the default react native
cli to give you a more complete starting
point when you open the app you'll
notice quite a few files here in the
root directory these are mostly config
files like metro and watchmen for hot
reloading buck is your build tool and
babel to transpile your javascript it
even ships with flow by default so it
feels very facebooky the app source code
is contained in the single app.js file
if we go ahead and open that file you'll
notice a bunch of react code this might
look familiar if you're a web developer
and the only real difference is that
we're importing special components from
react native and we use those in the jsx
instead of the typical html elements
that's our starting point for react
native now let's take a look at flutter
after installing the flutter sdk run
flutter create from the command line
you'll notice that it's considerably
faster because it doesn't have to reach
out to npm to download a bunch of
packages go ahead and open the project
in vs code and make sure that you have
the flutter extension installed it will
actually manage any additional packages
you install automatically in the
background the project structure here is
a little more simplified your main
config file is this pubspec.yaml file
which is equivalent to the package json
and the react native project this is
where you register and install
third-party packages the app source code
is contained in the main.dart file now
if you're a web developer who's never
touched typescript this code might look
kind of crazy with keywords like extends
super and override but if you have a
background in typescript java or c-sharp
then you'll likely feel right at home
with this code now that we have a
project set up i want to talk about
tooling which is really important when
building cross-platform mobile apps
because without good tooling your life
will be miserable let's start by serving
the react native app locally here i have
an android emulator running then i need
to run this adb command to connect to it
from there i run npm start to run metro
to watch my code for changes in the
background then in a separate terminal
enter npm run android to build the
android app this will install the app on
the emulator and listen to code changes
in the background to automatically
update the application we can also type
an r into the watchman terminal to hot
reload the app that's extremely useful
because it preserves the state of the
application while still reflecting your
code changes if you're iterating on the
design so that's essential but when it
comes to tooling with react native it's
really a create your own adventure story
it's just a javascript project so you
can throw in typescript or you might
want to use the ignite cli to
automatically generate boilerplate for
you or use expo to quickly launch the
app on your own device it's nice to have
a lot of options but that can also lead
to decision fatigue and an over reliance
on third parties now if we switch over
to the flutter app you'll notice a
button down here in vs code that allows
us to grab an emulator that's configured
on the local system we can then open the
terminal and enter flutter run and we
can also hot reload because dart
supports just in time compilation by
also typing an r into the terminal now
because dart has a sound type system
it's able to provide really nice tooling
as you write your code notice how when i
hover over any class it provides the
full documentation for it but more
importantly dart makes it really hard to
write code that results in runtime
errors if i try to pass an argument that
has the wrong data type it'll tell me
this code sucks right away instead of
waiting for it to pop up as an error at
runtime and that's especially important
for mobile apps because you live and die
by reviews in the app stores now you can
also add typescript to react native to
get similar results but dart does other
things like null safety to make your
code even more reliable now the other
interesting thing in the code is that
both frameworks create a tree of
components or widgets in react native it
looks like html or jsx where you have a
tag like view and then you add another
component inside of that and then maybe
more components inside of that
components might have state that changes
throughout the life cycle of the app and
react native will automatically
re-render the ui whenever the state
changes flutter works in the exact same
way and was actually very much inspired
by react but it goes about it in a much
different way instead of functions you
have classes that have a build method
which returns a tree of widgets each
widget is just a class instance and
might have a variety of different
properties that take other widgets as
arguments so it does the same basic
thing as react but it's just a different
approach to building declarative uis
when coding by hand it makes refactoring
more difficult in my opinion you can't
just copy and paste a component like you
would in react however flutter once
again has really good tooling that makes
it possible to wrap and reposition
widgets by simply clicking a button in
vs code now after building a chat app
with both frameworks one drawback i
found with flutter is that i would often
end up with these deeply nested widget
trees that are hard to follow you can
always extract this logic into your own
custom widgets but i just don't find the
process as intuitive as react where you
simply create a new function for each ui
component now the problem with react is
there often isn't a component to do
exactly what you want to do that means
you need to start with a base component
and then make it do what you want to do
or install a third-party package on top
of that a lot of react libraries aren't
compatible with react native like if you
want awesome animations with frame
remotion that's not going to fly and
react native now the final thing i want
to look at is performance you might be
wondering is flutter faster than react
native and the answer is most likely yes
the goal is generally to render at 60
frames per second and because flutter
apps are compiled directly to machine
code and don't require a javascript
bridge they tend to perform better based
on most benchmarks i could find on the
internet there's a good article that
i'll link to in the description that
breaks down a variety of different
benchmarks and as you can see flutter
gets much closer to native performance
however you have to ask yourself does
performance really matter for the
majority of apps out there performance
differences will be indistinguishable to
the end user but i suppose in react
native you might run into performance
bottlenecks sooner and if you really
care about performance your best option
is to just go truenative i'm gonna go
ahead and wrap things up there but if
you want to build these chat apps from
scratch check out fireship pro for a
couple of extra bonus videos there and
here's a special discount code for those
of you who watched the entire video
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one